seid ihr bereit für die leckersten
chorus schnitten der welt ich liebte es
über alles und ich habe mir gedacht
warum macht sich einfach schnitten raus
also lasst uns direkt starten kommt mit
[Musik]
für dieses geniale rezept werde ich
jetzt eine cheesecake masse
zusammenrühren und zwar nämlich der
doppel rahmen frischkäse ich bin daher
am liebsten philadelphia geschmeckt
halter salz arm aber wir könnten auch
gerne mal in die kommentare schreiben ob
ihre lieblings frischkäse habt und da
höre ich dann sahne zucker und vanille
der extrakt dazu leute wandel extrakt
ist der geschmacksträger hier im rezept
später kommt auch noch dazu weil tourbus
werden ja später in zimt zucker gewälzt
aber ich möchte sind noch nicht im teig
haben der kommt gleich erst zum einsatz
[Musik]
ich habe das ganze jetzt in einem
schneebesen verrühren aber auch nur kurz
also das war 10 15 sekunden nicht zu
lange damit der frischkäse nicht flüssig
wird und dann sonst ärgert die leute das
möchte ich nicht und ist es für vanille
ja es ist wie vanille aber ohne wandel
macht das ganze rezept keinen sinn und
es schmeckt so gut wie sieht man auch
richtig diese vanille pünktchen sarah
granzow
das sind meine luft genau so muss das
aussehen die so ich mache jetzt noch
zwei zutaten rein und zwar speisestärke
brauchen wir für die konsistenz ich
sieht die speisestärke auf jeden fall
noch mal damit da nachher keine
klümpchen entstehen und dann kommen noch
zwei eier dazu und die ganzen
mengenangaben die schreibe ich euch wie
immer unten in die infobox
[Musik]
in tal geht einmal kurz seite legen hier
brauchen wir gleich wieder ich habe
jetzt auch schon zimt und zucker
miteinander verrührt das brauchen wir
nämlich jetzt und was wir auch benötigen
ist dieser kurs ort
ihr seht einen fertigen teig leberkäs
kitchen aber dieses rezept durch umhauen
ist und einfach so praktisch und einfach
wie möglich sein und nein ich finde
persönlich ist lohnt sich nicht jetzt
ein croissant kann zu kneten und nehmen
dafür eben diesen aus dem wo er bisher
aus dem kühlregal genau und jetzt
einfach öffentlich mache so dass ein
teil unten auf dem boden kommt dann
kommt sie im zucker drauf und dann kommt
denn der andere teil quasi nochmal on
top
übrigens dieser teig dieser knack und
backtag den gebrauch von verschiedenen
firmen der kommt immer in so einer super
langen forma sie rollt den außenminister
ist halt super lang und wir wollen das
ja ein bisschen anders geformt haben
daher in der mitte einfach einmal
durchschneiden mit dem messer und wenn
ihr das dann so übereinander legt dann
habt ihr eigentlich die perfekten maße
ich nehme jetzt hier meinen
verstellbaren back rahmen aus dem shop
verlinke ich euch unten in der infobox
und habe jetzt hier auch mein backblech
mit backpapier dieses backblech ist auch
aus dem shop das ist das super gerade
ist also wenn ihr so ein gewölbtes habt
dann passt bitte auch nicht dass ihr
euch ärgert dadurch dass durch die
wölbung der cheesecake masse heraus
fließt das wäre nicht so schön und jetzt
ganz easy zimt zucker einfach hier auf
dem backpapier verteilen und da kommt
dann gleich einmal dieser croissant tag
um drauf und dann mache ich den bug ram
drumherum
[Musik]
yeah
so den zweiten saisonteil pflegen wir da
jetzt einfach oben drauf die cheesecake
masse ist jetzt nicht so fest dies auch
nicht so flüssig aber trotzdem müsst ihr
aufpassen ich wollte dass man aus und
die sind ja schon quasi vorgeschnitten
dadurch dass es ja eigentlich croissants
werden sollten daher auch hier wieder in
der hälfte gleich einmal durchschneiden
und am besten hier auf der arbeitsfläche
schon mal so diese löcher ganz leicht
zusammendrücken dann legen wir das oben
drauf dann kommt noch zimt zucker darauf
und dann packen wir es auch schon ich
kann mich ja schon mal die backzeit
verraten 180 grad ober und unterhitze
heizt den ofen schön vor und da braucht
brauchen die tour bus schnitten ca 30
minuten
[Musik]
b
klagen sie auch regelmäßig über
ausgelaufenen teig zu ross schnitten die
nicht funktionieren und einfach zu
postieren frustrierenden ergebnissen
führen setzen sie dem ein ende machen
sie die neue rezeptur von kirchs taurus
schnitt
[Musik]
und der brust gehört der vergangenheit
an fertig sind die zur ausschnitten
jetzt wundert euch wahrscheinlich warum
stehen hier zwei bleche ist die kirche
wieder so gefräßig dass sie sich direkt
zwei gemacht hat na ja also das war mein
rezept experiment das waren fällig werde
es trotzdem essen sieht halt nur nicht
so schön aus hiess sehr viel ausgelaufen
der teig also der sah diese cheesecake
macht einfach zu flüssig und die
backzeit hat nicht gepasst und das ist
meine perfektionierte variante die euch
natürlich hat präsentiert und ganz
wichtig ist dass ihr das komplett
auskühlen das nicht weiß dass es immer
die schönste bart man hat nie geduld
nach dem backen das noch auskühlen zu
lassen aber erst dann wird er fest und
erst dann kann man da auch so richtig
schönes stückchen rausschneiden und
später gibt es natürlich wieder den test
mit hamza habenseite noch nicht probiert
also noch gar nicht und ich bin einfach
nur gespannt wie er sich findet
[Musik]
ok hamza wir machen den test ich will
einfach nur so gespannt würde ich
aufgeregt weil auch krieg waren also ich
hab's probiert ich bin durchgedreht euch
bezug auf hansa krass ist gar kein
ausdruck also leute gesagt das wird das
nächste oder nicht so trennt das wird
der nächste hype da hab ich so was
schadet das nicht probiert mit so
wenigen zutaten und sondern einfach um
20 uhr geht's los das sind schnitten
besser gesagt in drin ist so an einem
schieß cache angenehm also war einfach
alles was ich liebe schießt das ist das
nächste ding olg ist auch so kann das
ein bisschen wie sonst passiert ist so
weil ich ja das ist sehr weit ja heute
so richtig weiß also wirklich gespannt
hast unternehmens stück das ist krank
der geschmack als würdest du auch noch
zu hoch und auch einem new york
cheesecake beißen nur noch geiler noch
mal auf ein anderes level bis sprachlos
so die feier willkommen schon
heftig ohne whisky schmeckt richtig geil
gegen endlich auf uns zu essen ich habe
gerade schon ein stück ist es schmeckt
so heftig also schon das richtig lecker
ich finde sich nicht von dieser welt ich
persönlich beschreiben die sich für das
vom kraft für alle die sich nicht
vorstellen können weil es etwas ganz
neues es ist somit eines jahres kate
habe schon bei gästen so und ich weiß
nicht schmeckt oder selber naja das wird
jetzt in mode lahm keine ahnung das ist
so geil also für alle die sich das nicht
vorstellen können wir haben ja unten
einmal in diesem ressort teig und oben
nochmal on top und will ist das schon
sehr weich war also gut weiß man kommt
super mit der gabel durch die cheesecake
masse ist total soft und intensiv war
nämlich und obendrüber diese decke die
ist für mich für mich ist das highlight
wettgemacht es fehlen die worte ich mal
sagen ich habe richtig 6 so seien so
krass wirklich guten jahren kaufte ich
weiß gar nicht wie ich das definiert wo
ist das jetzt auch nicht mehr so
ängstlich oder russland das gibt dann
über über über weltmeister gar nicht
hätte ich für ihn macht einfach machen
ich habe gemerkt man die reaktionen zu
krass genau direkte sogar er hoffe im
bild vertreten durch komplett oder
sprachlos und sprache sogar noch ein
bisschen besser ich bin gerade beides
ist gleich schlecht rückt also was soll
ich sagen leute wäre das nicht nach
machten selbst schuld also wirklich ihr
verpasst was einfach machen und genießen
ist zunächst mal genau deswegen liebe
geht durch den magen
das beste beispiel tap gehören
[Musik]